well our next two guest actors Dylan
McDermott and Jeremy Sisto star in
tonight's three-hour FBI crossover event
imminent threat on CBS McDermott is a
two-time Emmy nominee for his TV roles
on the practice and Hollywood ciso
starred in the emmy-winning series six
feet under and the classic film clueless
well now McDermott plays supervisory
special agent Remy Scott and FBI Most
Wanted and Sisto stars as assistant
special agent in charge Jubal Valentine
in FBI and in tonight's crossover event
their teams along with FBI International
joined forces when an American Citizen's
abduction in Rome is connected to an
international Terror plot in New York
City here's a preview
C4 what else Nico looking for plastic
explosives that's what I've been trying
to figure out for the past three weeks
anything else you can tell me
what I know and what I can give yeah
you're like Mother Teresa all you do is
give we think Nico is working with some
serious people from Belarus
and their military that means the people
that are working with over here
are seriously so back in New York we got
someone working undercover agent school
and he's trying to pin down a foreign
buyer who's looking to acquire
industrial grade explosives okay and you
two are here in person so you must think
this is an imminent threat
weeks it could be days but yeah someone
wants to hit New York
well Dylan McDermott and Jeremy Sisto
welcome good to have you both here
thanks for having us yeah so Dylan this
is your very first FBI crossover event
what was it like being a part of this I
mean what an exciting three hours three
hours three shows how many teams it
feels that way yeah so I think tonight
just lock it in on CBS eight o'clock and
go to 11 and you're going to be for
inter A Thrill Ride yeah that's right
Jeremy you said that um this is your
James Bond moment because your character
travels to Rome after American was
kidnapped why is this your James Bond
well well Jubal does an isn't chasing
criminals with guns every week right and
certainly not
um uh through lavish Estates that are
centuries old and in underground tunnels
and uh over ruins so he is you know my
son would say jubal's his favorite
character in front of me but it's
probably OA but when he visited set in
Rome he was pretty impressed with my
weaponry and my some of the moves Jubal
was making
Valentine that's right well done so
Dylan you posted a video of you running
with a dummy right why a were you
running with a dummy and B uh is that
important to keep it light keep it fun
yeah oh you got oh look at that yes what
has happened
I was doing I had to carry a security
guard so they they gave me a dummy to
carry initially to see what it was like
but then I I always make jokes on set
and write my own jokes for the show and
uh I think it's important because it's
such a heavy subject matter we're
dealing with you know the most heinous
criminals sure that I think it's you
know you have to offset it and explain
how the teams work together because this
is an international Case an abduction
and how it brings it all back to a
threat of terrorism possibly in New York
yeah yeah well I mean I I think really
it all led up to this episode tonight
this is really using the concept of the
show in the greatest form
um we have an international team uh we
have a team that travels Across America
chasing the worst criminals and we have
a a team in the America's most populated
and important city and that leads to a
sprawling story that our our Rick EAD
our showrunner who broke the story and
Dick Wolf and all the team uh were very
thoughtful in how to make this episode
emotional engaging exciting and and just
really live up to the promise of the
show no always fascinated by these types
of shows because you can watch an
episode and it seems as if it's pulled
from the headlines and then you can
watch another episode it's almost like
it's predicting the headlines it is what
is it like to work on a show like did
you mention emotional and sometimes
these topics can be heavy Dylan for you
you've been in this business a long time
both of you have but what is it like
when you're doing a show and you see
maybe the story lines mimicked
throughout our country yeah I mean
honestly it's sad because it is so much
of what's happening in the world today
there's a lot of bad things out there
unfortunately and and this show does
predict
uh what is next or what happened or
right so it is dark
um unfortunately and New York is also a
big part of this tonight's show yeah
um so you know I think the world's in in
struggle in many ways yeah and a show
like this I think why why people love it
so much is because at the end of it
there is some kind of resolution right
and in life there's not always
resolution you know so you feel
satisfied knowing that we're going to
catch the bad guy do you have those kind
of conversations with your son you
mentioned you watch it with your son how
old is he and do you talk about those
kinds of issues that Dylan's talking
about or do you talk about the acting or
what's it like that experience certainly
well I think one of the one of the um uh
Talent stick and his is uh his team have
with with most of shows is to bring up
very important and controversial topics
without necessarily taking aside you
know walking away before he arrives at
any anything and on our show the FBI you
know we're dramatizing their true
objectives which are to save American
lives predict threats and so uh yeah we
we talk about all the serious stuff uh
with our kids um maybe to a fault um but
uh we we've always been like that and
and
um maybe we need more of a filter but
it's good they have to have ideas no
it's important but speaking of kids I
know Dylan you've got a proud dad moment
coming up because your daughter Colette
she's an actress and she's got a role
coming up in FBI's Most Wanted yes not
this week but next week uh she is on the
show as a guest star I've been looking
for a role all season and finally I
centered the script she auditioned for
it she got the role and not only is my
daughter on this show but my dog the dog
plays my undercover dog what speaking of
that dog who's playing there he is
what's his name Otis oh
yeah
this is the first time we've had a very
well well-behaved dog
the boy we can't pick him up anyway
well yes she has his own vest yes
um and uh not a leg right metal leg he's
ready to rock hey John can I use you for
a second so I'm trying to get a dog for
quite some time I talked to the camera
maybe once a show back to the camera and
tell my wife a Toya is her name and why
would she get it okay this is all I need
to do that's what I'm saying come on
baby yeah what's your name
where is she yeah there you go okay
atoya yes look what we got here boom
this is all you need
all love all day he's working all the
time yeah come on
Dylan okay thank you so much and we're
gonna see if Nate gets his dog out of
this we'll keep you updated on that you
can catch the three-hour Global
crossover event that's tonight at 8pm
Eastern and Pacific right here on CBS
and streaming on